Alice successful return here at the
Saint Louis chess club but today wasn't
easy you got a very decent position out
of the opening but it felt like she
slowly got back into the game how did
you leave this game
um yeah so the opening I actually didn't
really like the position I got after
um I thought like maybe I shouldn't have
um passant like DJ C6
um did you know that you're following
yasser's good friend Victor no I didn't
know this game I wasn't really preparing
for like this
decline
I mean I thought it would be possible
but A5 I think usually instead of A5 the
main move is F5
um and then there's some like lines
after that that's right um but so after
I saw I knew like A5 had to be like
better for me
um I was expecting like 97.91 F5 uh but
she played net H6 which I think is also
okay yeah
um more or less I think Knight G5 at
this did you consider this move oh no I
didn't this was a really good option for
you it was giving you a tremendous
Advantage yeah that looks very good just
so that after Knight H6 then you get the
Knight to E6 and this one feels good but
you play Knight E1 and uh it felt like
slowly slowly she was getting back into
the game especially after this move D5
yeah actually I felt like after D5
um my position was more pleasant to play
like I knew objectively I should
probably still like I shouldn't be too
much better but
um I thought if I was ever able to trade
Queens then game would be pretty
Pleasant for me
um because I have the past be upon the B
Pawn
but uh yeah after
um this
yeah after rookie six I thought Rick D1
my position was quite good
um Bishop B3 and then I calculated this
line uh
oh with like Bishop A2 Rook she had this
move route to B8 maybe the best option
in the position yeah I thought like I
would play maybe bishop D7 but I guess
like after Bishop C4 then she can take
with another E6 and then I'll lose the
exchange fast yes and of course this is
not easy stuff and finally now she gets
your b-pawn right with bishop f8 and
things of that nature but it still
remained very complicated it felt like
she fell through the cracks after this
move Bishop to A2 yeah after I Bishop 82
I was very happy because because after
work F2 Rook takes A2
and then I knew I thought like here I
should be winning I calculated like
record six B5
um and yeah my Bishops are just too good
I thought like her work on E6 has a very
few squares to go
how do you generally feel in the first
few rounds uh does it take a while for
you to warm up or do you feel like
you're very dangerous in the first few
rounds what type of player are you
um I mean I guess it depends I think
last year I started out uh pretty poorly
like I got one out of the first four
rounds
um and I actually never won a first
round game in the US Junior Heroes
Championship so getting this first round
the win was nice and I guess it also
depends on like the parents who you're
playing what color you get
um so overall I don't think like I have
like a specific very good first round or
very bad first round although
um it's probably leaning more towards
like a very bad first round to feel like
a slower start yeah
guys any questions for Alice oh first of
all Alice uh we just want to say
congratulations you've been having a
kind of breakout year for yourself
everything's going so well what are you
doing right
um our viewers want to know
yeah I've been playing in like a lot of
Throne tournaments
um I had like two back-to-back
tournaments right before this uh and
like another tournament a few
tournaments in June so I think just like
playing in these really strong
tournaments have given me a lot more
experience playing against strong
players
um and that definitely has like helped
me improve in the past year
your big rival in this event is Carissa
Yip tell us about the Rivalry what are
you looking forward to in this
tournament when you meet
um yeah I
at seven
um so isn't one of the later rounds so
for now I'll just focus on I guess the
next few rounds but um it would
definitely be like really great to play
here since she was one of my biggest
Idols that I looked up to for so many
tournaments and to play against her
would just be a very good experience
wow that's so amazing like you see some
19 year olds being like role models for
13 years old that's amazing I'm
surprised that you never met because I
know both of you already competed in the
U.S women's championships but I guess
Karissa maybe did not buy the year you
did yeah I think Carissa
um played 2020 uh 2021
um she skipped last year yeah she
skipped last year and that was the first
year that I was in because of college
yes yes wow nice well good luck for the
rest of the tournament absolutely uh
Alice uh everybody's cheering for you
accept your opponents
I just wanted to say uh in the game